first the fragrant curry paste roast  coriander and cumin seeds into aromatic  [Music]  then grind adding crushed garlic chilli  powder turmeric and finely chopped  ginger  [Music]  bring together with olive oil to form a  thick paste for the soup by finely  chopped onions in olive oil  add the curry paste and cook to release  the flavors add cute potatoes chicken  stock and season when the potato has  softened stirring creamed corn  [Music]  then add whole sweet corn kernels with  some of the juices and transfer to a  blender and blitz until smooth  for texture add more whole sweet corn  heat and is ready to serve  [Music]  wonderfully satisfying curried spiced  sweet corn soup that packs an amazingly  aromatic punch